[Music]
that's the end of
everything the
beginning the begin of
everything the idea was a competition
everyone is tested to determine who we
are that's nothing to smile about yay
this is the best day of my
life oh am so Happ
are you ready for the most romantic week
of your entire
life you Ling
me have you fallen out of love with
me
no what out there now bro happen why
would you do that you can't take that
back there is evil in this world and it
is going to send us back to the Stone
Age holy
you guys just woke as sleeping
giant it will be the end of mankind as
we know it welcome to the darkness
I am not
afraid then come out then you'll be
[Music]
afraid
ch